[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have pokey she's a really
really huge huge huge just leaves in
general it's pretty much how many
followers do you have you not surprised
I mean she's huge
question you actually look like your
photos don't see people where they look
like we see them in person we're like oh
there's some facetune going it was one
girl that was in our skit and then geo
casted her and she was very beautiful
and her photos she was a beautiful in
real life but when you look up close her
face was like the Sahara Desert
it was cracking she didn't even look old
that other one that one's bad too
yeah can I be honest I always have like
that thing in the back of my mind that's
like what if I'm just really ugly and
all my friends are too nice to tell me
would tell you if anything I thought you
guys just wouldn't say anything
yeah yeah yeah well I will call you ugly
but you're not ugly so good for you
nobody you know I think we talked about
you a few years ago yeah okay I think it
was like a year ish ago and it was so
crazy to me because I've known of you
guys for so long like so long I just
first started or even when I was like in
high school oh [ __ ] we're old it's been
a while that I've known of you guys and
then I had all that like make a drama
blah blah blah and to hear you guys talk
about I was like [ __ ] like this really
this some [ __ ] went down you know yeah
yeah what's the make up drama what did
we talk to the body was the one where
she keeps she went on the stream with no
makeup and then people were talking [ __ ]
okay can I be honest what did I say
about you what do you apologize no no
yeah to be completely honest um do you
remember what the guy said wherever the
girls are really nice they're like you
know you just look like that oh I
remember the guy said and I think it
might have been you you guys did
spinning a bunch of dirty to brunch and
that's maybe this week
you said something like - no girl is
just like um sometimes when you wear a
lot of makeup like you don't get a lot
of Sun so when you completely take it
off like you look really pale and you're
not as good to see what if you like
sponge a week away in vacation and then
had no makeup no no so I'll saw that's
good cool look I was just like confused
cuz like you have great skin like it
didn't look like it wasn't like oh my
god what a completely different person
it was like you just look like the same
person but without know yeah I had no
makeup and my hair was a mess it was
like you only rock one or the other you
know or LC for like who is this usually
from guys that's never lived with a girl
before we had sex they didn't they never
had sex yes I always blog with no makeup
in here because I want you to get used
to bare bottom level and then if I dress
up and you're like oh smart streaming um
I've been streaming since I was 17 I'm
23 now so weird six years yeah it's
great because like you feel like between
17 and 23 like you're at such different
stages of life and to think that I've
been more or less doing the same thing
or at least putting myself out there on
the internet throughout that whole stage
of my life getting a masters in gaming
or twitch is streaming how many
followers do you have on what twitch
that the top top three okay YouTube
twitch and Instagram twitch is probably
bigger than YouTube for her she's
streamer actually they're so close no
it's just like it's so important to grow
on YouTube in order to grow on Twitch as
well in my opinion so twitch I'm like
three point two or three point three ml
Oh YouTube I'm not like three point
eight or not it's like all of our
channels come by a girl good job can you
can you talk about me on your social
media when you get a chance
can you help us get some trout because
we're like old school it's it you know
it's okay y'all just saw make a tic TOCs
or something I don't know what's tick
tock below me yeah is when you talk
about ticks a lot a minute everyone gets
informed on it
I love expression those shoes it's like
oh I don't even want to tell you what it
is do you have a quick totally no yeah
but I don't really use it that much I
just know it's possibly a vine but with
musically combined yeah oh that's such a
good way to explain it and even five
she's our youngest member got in so that
I really am a new marketing strategy
from her I just I just opened up a
myspace account if anyone wants to add
me topping me on top of you
right yeah I think Bart thinks you're
serious I'm serious
good job I'm a Joe's dad to do anything
so I thought it was like we visit in the
past yeah that's why I said I think he's
you're joking you think Bart's serious
though it's myspace hasn't closed oh no
no Justin Timberlake bought it a couple
years ago did music platform now
really Wow that's all you're painting
going he's you pink
I didn't once it was really fun like
what kind of paint like a canvas
painting I did a Bob Ross tutorial and
they turned out way better than everyone
thought it was actually no no because
like I haven't painted since like the
10th grade but I gotta say it was not me
it was Bob Ross he just has a way of
making whatever the heck in doing look
this you made someone happy little trees
yeah yeah it's the white guy would
happen okay you know we watch you for
you you know we watch you for you the
girl that dressed up as a man yeah
that's Bob Ross
yo euphoria was live so I mole in
episode 4 okay okay okay ah something
not a boiler related and also not really
related to everything so sorry this is
such a tangent but our high Oh nowadays
really like that or in America I don't
know you're probably closer to high
school than we are yeah but also I'm
from Canada Canada is like oh we just
sit around you guys play hockey everyone
else I chose and I still happens because
I watch Degrassi growing up and that
should still is very really I'd even
watch Degrassi to be like enough it's
really all right I've only ever seen
like one kid get bullied but those it o
is great I love Canada was that like was
it like I was like that's legit I was
like that's so weird what are you doing
what happens in Canada like Canadian
schools like what kind of like you just
study nothing you actually do your
homework like what I guess it depends so
you know there's still cliques and stuff
but there's no teen pregnancy there was
under grass one me one one yeah during
my four years I read involved in Cologne
or two and those are like them like
massive news you know wow yeah I mean
there's still like the drama and this
and that but I guess what I feel like is
in Canada the spectrum isn't so large
sometimes when I watch like TV about um
our TV shows about high school in
America it's like you're super popular
doing all the drugs figure like such a
loser getting bullied all the time for
us it's just like yeah there's like cool
quicksand there's non-coal cliques but
and also America I don't know if did it
but maybe it was also my school I want
to like a bit high school - well you it
might be a difference between small town
and big cities
oh yeah that's cuz out here - like we
have that and we have rich kid school we
have like poor kid school all that stuff
the grass he made me feel like everyone
was gonna try to get me to do all their
drugs and then yeah I think you get to
the high school and like everyone wants
to keep their drugs they watch - what
did we watch it I watched Saved by the
Bell
yeah that - no let's make us Berg I
wanted to be Kelly Kapowski
we do cuz she was pretty
no I don't want it to be jessie spano me
yes because we were in elementary school
and we're like I can't wait to get to
high school cuz it's gonna be like saved
by the band yeah you can have giant
phones yeah yeah that was before your
time Oh remind me how old I am
Gio I wanted to be Kelly Kapowski but I
wanted to date screech whoa
he wasn't even funny I thought he was so
goofy I loved him no anyone wanted
screams yeah cute but I'm surprised you
didn't want AC Slater I thought you
liked josh lopez with that AC yeah just
waiter
AC Slater no yeah weird curly hair yeah
that's owned it now your son has curly
hair he has wavy it is a difference okay
so how long have you lived in this state
I may be to LA about two and a half
years ago I think are you a citizen now
I have a visa resident you notice it
tastes like five or ten years to be
honest citizen yeah haven't gotten like
a green card yeah so how does that work
stay here so I have to stay here three
years but the process to get the visa
was so bad because we're they like
Jamie's not a real job
oh yeah it just takes a while like you
have to basically prove that you're
important show the check mark oh you
need like my gran reference letters of
companies that I'd worked with and you
need someone at each company to be like
this is what we've done together this is
what I feel we could do together and
this is why it's important for them to
come to the United States yeah and like
just getting those letters takes a hot
minute to like get approvals from every
legal team at every company oh and it
was like right as Trump came into office
I think and he also made the process
harder so I don't even know what it's
like nowadays I have friends I'll try to
get visas I just don't think it's gonna
happen
whoa what is your visa like you know
some people have student visa working
are you in ER called an old visa visa
like oh damn you famous girl like
I hate to explain it it's like
extraordinary person like that's darling
oh my god on that like you're an
important person in your field great
work to the United nothing a reason why
you did that cuz you couldn't just
illustrate a stream from Canada oh my
god you're like I need to be I need a
card that shows it everything the whole
gaming and sports
ecosystem is in LA everything's in LA
really because you have some friends are
trying to go to Austin for gaming
Austin kind of Austin is like y'all got
good internet and cheaper taxes but la
it's like where all the conventions and
the events are and all that um I do to
be honest I'm like in my room most of
the time I work from home all the time
so it's like Shrive been in LA for like
two years but I have the experience of
someone that's been here like six months
really like I just want a little Tokyo
for the first time yeah I loved it
already Japan and so going back was just
like I didn't go back to Japan
immediately yeah it gives you those
buyers huh I love it I just feel like I
saw so much to explore in LA it's huge
to there's so many areas each little
lick nook could be a different City of
LA yeah yeah technically la is from the
beach all the way to Riverside which is
San Bernardino County do you know where
this that's no 60-mile radius or
something like so I'm sure like 10 or 20
miles diameter yeah I like that though
you're like oh I understand la is
massive I don't know where look that way
me see mountains oh that's where it is
okay I understand right past the
mountain yeah you go past a little bit
yeah yeah
dude I lived here my whole life and
there's still pockets of la that I'm
like what the [ __ ] is this yeah like
when you read Monterey Park on a call
sheet you're like the fun never had an
audition there we just went to the
Hollywood sign like last year it's
actually really cool Clark yeah and
people have a picnic and then like the
sunny like minutes past I've only ever
been to the Griffith Observatory and
seen it from there oh it's right next to
it you could have hit two birds with one
stone you messed up I did the Lord my
school [ __ ] up because that's where we
had our field trips and stuff stupid
school who needs school don't go to
school cool so how'd you come up with
your name cuz I know it's like so your
name is Iman and they're like pokemons
yeah it was meant to be like my name and
the game Pokemon combines people read it
in English and it's like paquimé me or
whatever or I guess pokey main now yeah
so I'm like I'll just roll with it like
I'm not trying to surpass broy bulky
mine yeah the idea was to have it be
Pokemon because my name is Iman and the
game Pokemon yeah I'm gonna pokie pokie
it's just like a cute nickname it is
seriously pokey pokey the birth rate in
Gumby and I all put the hook
you [ __ ] crap mom are the full data
house [ __ ] like this you pick it up no
I'm not worse with references it's
embarrassing
yeah I mean even reference it's like my
generation I just don't know anything
it's sometimes I kind of worries like
what was one thing that you're like oh
my god I should know every like there's
a movie even Star Wars Harry Potter I
don't know if like something traumatic
happened when I was a trauma just forgot
I think the alternative is just that um
I mean I feel like Canadian and American
culture is a bit different in terms of
what we watched growing up yeah on top
of that I grew up in like um we're
pretty traditional like the Middle
Eastern household so we didn't watch it
none of the event is [ __ ] Oh what were
you watching these there cartoons you
watch Aladdin
oh yeah sure what even that that was
your only reference these Middle Eastern
yeah when I pictured Middle Eastern
cartoons I'm thinking like Middle
Eastern Sesame Street or something no I
really just think I grew up on the
Internet's like I remember really odd
old memes that like no one else's like
what
try me Oh guys do you remember that I
heard you like mudkips me yeah did you
get that one my wizard robe mm-hmm
funny though because our reference of
old memes is like after we were already
well out of high school in college we're
like I was like old memes like Ebaum's
world I mean yeah Oh mind blown
23 that is when me and Bart just started
making our first YouTube videos and
you're already successful at 23 damn
girl
imagine when you're our age nah nah same
thing with me there's like is Billy how
much like 16 or something no yeah it's
just like massively successful I like
that's a good flex we would never say
that because we're like like Billy
Eilish is over there we're like all the
way there no my Floyd is just like I
feel like we're in a day and age we're
just like as the years go on younger
people won't yeah just have an easier
time because social media like social
media wasn't around really when you guys
started like there was no way to way to
get the reward
[Laughter]
well like those kids the [ __ ] play
with toys those you know those kids that
play the toys they're like beyond Ryan's
book mary has his own TV show on
Nickelodeon I mean that's some
next-level [ __ ] that's cool that is
money that's [ __ ] money he's too
young to say [ __ ] you fudge you money
that's I don't care about you money yeah
we're not friends my Korean now till
forever
I think that's insane yeah you had the
sister to right well he probably has
enough money to translate it into
whatever he wants
how are your parents when you were like
playing games all the time were they
like what are you doing with your life
okay um I actually don't really talk
about this that much but looking back on
it I realized that like one of the
reasons I played games so much was
because like my parents were kind of
strict and like protective it yeah
you're not out past sunset
no boys in the house you know stuff like
that so it's like what else might you do
today home play video games yeah I feel
like that that kept me like really
fulfilled and happy oh one of the
reasons why like I see a lot of kids who
are maybe
under like strict households like that
growing up and then they leave and they
just rebelled from now she's like happy
playing video games when I turn 18 now
it's still happy foot you're like the
perfect kid don't go out fine [ __ ] do
they go like you're only successful
because of me because I forced you to
stay inside and play video games now
give me money
no actually like I always want to spend
money on that and they won't let me if
anything like my mom will call me up
she'll be like okay know how successful
you are no I'm like oh I'll tell her
like how much I'm making or whatever and
she'll still calm everything do you need
are you an only child back home nah my
brother - he's three years older than me
oh that's early of connecting yeah um
growing up he was always like the guy
who is actually gaming a lot and I was a
bit more studious even though I still
gained but like I was really into school
as well and then he ended up finishing
his engineering degree and became an
engineer and now I play video games on
YouTube video games I mean yeah where's
my job I gotta meet him and then throw
money at him to your head they're
feuding like we beautiful we play we
play games together and like posted on
my youtube channel are you guys feuding
no did you guys ever feud yes not
growing up oh he was actually the reason
I never played FPS games
so like shooter game really you saw my
face there's also a third person shooter
there's no second person issues first
between the two it's literally like how
zoomed in you are like can you see your
character if you can't see your
character that's like isn't that a mode
though like I remember back in the day
like counter-strike you could either be
like like this or it could be the person
is in front of times but there's certain
games that's like one or the other I
think csgo is first-person and like for
tonight a third-person and it's like you
what's your favorite type of game to
play
it's really hard to say I like maybe
MMOs
also though there's like a difference
between the games that you enjoy to play
on your off time and my games that you
play on stream who's like what's popular
what's trending and stuff not only
what's shredding what's popular but like
what is more enjoyable for a viewer to
watch for example like I'm happy like
mine crafting away for three hours but
I'm like not saying [ __ ] but not as many
people want to watch that as they want
to watch me like play scary game and
like pee my pants every two seconds you
know I mean it's like you're never gonna
play like a scary game casually I mean
you can but yeah it's not as enjoyable
so my son recently got me and my husband
into minecraft so now every night we're
already four nights in a row we've been
spending hours on my goodness we did
that a few years ago did you guys get
all the the like obsidian to make a
gateway to hell yet not yet oh it's like
an adventure it's really like no yeah so
we have three different worlds it's like
one with the three of us which we call
tick pissed if Isaac and Casey and then
the other one is called tick which is
tiffin Isaac and the other one is it's a
queer I think you see in that one they
have another oh that's so cute like I
want to be like my kids someday yeah I
was just my parents played games too but
after you get to the nether what do you
do cuz that's hers we stopped yeah it's
a mind stuff you kill like the boss
there oh that's big ol boss there and
you can still create portals like within
the nether what and there's like so many
different biomes I don't know if you've
seen all of them there's like sandy
there have you seen the pandas oh that's
something I really seeing the panner
there's so much left for me to learn and
like not only are there big penis they
make baby pee oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]